all right belle
we're going back to vietnam first time
perseus pinged our radar
it was late january 68. we were a joint
c.i.a
task force embedded within the third
marine regiment near danae
zog was there to sniff out soviet
activity
word had it russian operatives were
active in the region perseus had no
known presence
in vietnam that changed at the nag
somehow
perseus knew about operation fracture
jaw fracture jaw
that one sure went sideways we launched
out of camp haskins
yeah i'll never forget that [ __ ]
good we want those memories no details
too small
a face a name we're looking for anything
that can lead us to perseus this feels
like looking for a needle in a haystack
in a field of haystacks maybe but that
needle somewhere
remember we had a job
[Music]
fractured jaw that one sure went
sideways
bell it's time to wake up
it's great time
so
welcome to another day in the life of
camp haskins little oasis in the middle
of this godforsaken [ __ ] storm
you're pretty safe
[Music]
hey butcher how's the arm don't hurt
mike now at least i can move it
hey sims you know reading that shit's
gonna make you go blind
yup that's why i want it all up here
mel you're with sims usually bring out
the best at each other
[Music]
we got a new assignment fob4
ripcord is holding a vital asset charlie
wants real bad
what kind of asset are we talking about
the kind you don't ask about
ripcord has been taking a hell of a
beating so it's our job to secure the
asset and get the [ __ ] out
relax we got fast players providing
combat air support for this mission
it'll be a walk in the park
headsets on
all birds chicken when ready badger
niner one good to go
imagine two clear to go manager nine or
three rotors up
why do i get the feeling you about to
give us some bad news
because you're a smart guy sims the news
isn't bad in fact it could be very
very good the asset of ripcord is going
to have to wait a little while
we're breaking off from the armada
taking a detour and
that's good because the source tipped us
off that there may be a heavy hitter in
town
a soviet operative known as perseus oh
[ __ ] appreciate the enthusiasm sims
our source is right we could be looking
at an intel gold mine
first time perseus pinned our radar
[Music]
approaching the village now
rpg
god
taking us down
you and me bill let's do it
my priority is securing any intel
in the center of town
[Music]
keep pushing forward getting close
my name is
that's the building
keep your hands down
[Music]
uh
right
area clear okay get inside
see what we got
[Music]
[Music]
so
go bill i'm right behind you
hit the cover
[Music]
let's go
taking a look
[Music]
it's like looking for a needle in a
haystack you hear that it's on you bell
open
well i'm staring at two bodies that sure
as hell don't look vietnamese to me
bell grab that comms log let's see who
the [ __ ] they've been talking to
[Music]
mission accomplished we have the intel
let's bug out
good work hang on to that intel we're
coming in to pick you up
all right let's go rejoin the armada and
get this [ __ ] asset
[Music]
badger niner one this is ripcord we are
still under heavy fire
vc you're breaching the perimeter what
is your status
we're inbound now ripcord get that asset
ready for transfer
roger that niner one we'll keep the
assets safe as long as we can
rip cord out
bill
[Music]
[Music]
yes
you can do this that's it stay on
i think you got it good job
base 20 seconds
watch yourself
suggested
watch the cave bounce it's a duck in
it fire
oh
take out those
you need to push back the vc
reinforcements before we're overrun
we have multiple birds
we don't have a hope in how it landed if
we don't take out those positions
roger that record
yes
much longer hold on
the base is still hot so watch
yourselves roger that ripcord
you adler mac v suck yeah yeah just
hurry the [ __ ] up already yes sir
thank you don't thank me thank belle
he's the one who just said got the
[ __ ] phone book full of soviet intel
let's go now godspeed commander
a [ __ ] nuke are you [ __ ] kidding
me ethel it's a failsafe that's all you
need to know
be that desperate already not yet
rpg
[Music]
somehow percy is new
okay
well let loose with that goddamn turf
before we're overrun
we need air support well call it in
grab a weapon keep down the [ __ ] off us
where's that air support
so
yes
oh
oh still with us
you think we can call this a success
sims
at least the nuke didn't go off
more importantly we got intel on perseus
told you we had a job to do it ain't
done yet not by a long way
yeah how did the memory exercise go
well to hear it from adler it's working
bell remembered finding that encrypted
intel in vietnam and is almost finished
decoding it
anything useful in there some names
apparently
possible leads mark is trying to connect
the dots
we don't have much time does the team
know about
our mishap in berlin yet
no but if it's connected to one of those
names from bell they'll find out soon
enough
you won't let that happen hudson don't
say anything more
than necessary that's never been a
problem for me
we finished analyzing the names bella
quiet at da nang
one in particular stands out anton
volkov he's a russian arms dealer
working out of east berlin admittedly
his connection to perseus comes as a
surprise
we've got killer capture orders on
volkov
so if we can't get to perseus we'll get
to his men
close off his resources force him out of
hiding
woods are still wrapping up business in
kiev
which means volkov is ours gear up
and we'll move out